Dude, he wanted to knock that dude out so
bad after he got knocked out in the MMA
fight.
He wanted to knock him out in his rules.
And I think that is what you saw with
Cody this weekend. Too much emotion.
One fight.
Yeah man.
We were talking about that and watching
the replays like you could see in his
face that every shot
he was trying to knock
came out with. As soon as I saw
him walk, I mean not walk out.
I said he looked okay walking out as soon
as it's like the bell rung, I was like,
he just did. He looked a
little stiff. Yeah. You know,
and I was hoping he would shake it
off, get in the rhythm, like land,
a couple jabs, just like,
you know, we were working on,
when I spar with them a couple
times leading up to the TJ fight,
I'll go up to Alpha male to do my
wrestling. And a lot of my grappling, um,
you know,
they have so many 130 545 pounders up
there that it's only an hour and half away
drive. Right. It only makes sense to
go up there and exchange knowledge.
So, you know, as soon as I saw him walk
out and started the fight, I was like,
I hope she just, he just shakes it off
and like gets into his, his groove.
Like when he fought dom like artwork,
that was, that was incredible.
He just let him come to him
and I was hoping that that was,
what was his game plan? No
cause fucking man. So no,
he,
he wanted to use more wrestling from what
we were talking to Danny and all those
guys about it. He wanted to use more
wrestling and definitely a lot of kicks.
He wanted to kick a little bit as well.
But he also wanted to just do the same
thing to what he did to dom, you know,
just kind of like piece of mobe.
And I mean considering the last fight,
he almost finish him in the first round
when they first fought, he was like,
I can, I can do this.
I can finish this guy.
Well I think he could finish
anybody. Yeah. But it's,
he's got to go about it the right way.
And I thought he was going about it
the right way initially with the kicks.
And I was like, look, even if
these are just landing on the arms,
like these are going to soften TJ up.
These are brutal.
He was throwing some brutal kicks it,
and it was a totally different thing.
He was,
he was adding a whole different aspect
to the fight that he did in the first
part. And it wasn't, it
wasn't, uh, it, it, it, it,
when he started throwing the kicks, I was
like, yeah, there's the game plan. I see,
I see what's going beautiful.
And then when he pointed to the ground and
he was like, yes, he couldn't touch me.
I'm like, oh, he's starting
to get in this rhythm.
But that's what I hate about immediate
rematches after knockout. It's just,
it's still in your head. It's just
the confidence level, the anger,
the emotion. Like, you know, Henry two,
three years between his fight with Dj,
where he got finished in the first round
or fights fighting some other people.
Uh, he was a different human. Absolutely.
But if he had fought
DJ the very next fight,
who knows how that goes,
right?
That would be hard to sell less.
Henry was the champion and
Dj took the crown from him.
This was the whole idea was that,
you know,
Cody had beat dom Cody was the champ
and that Cody was defending the honor of
Alpha male and Tj was this snake in the
grass. They were gonna put away, you know,
that was the whole idea behind the
ultimate fighter. And it was just so,
I don't think there's ever been a fight
other than maybe Ronda and Meesha that
had more emotion, just more, you
know, bad blood by the rendezvous.
Ameesha thing might've been worse.
It's,
people don't remember how
hated Rhonda was after that.
Meesha Fike she wouldn't shake me.
She's hand like me.
She tried to shake your hand
and Ron was like, bitch could,
I didn't just walk away from
Marinette. And everyone's like, whoa.
Like why was interviewing her was just
blew the whole audience was booing those
emotional fights. They're so
compelling to watch, but man,
there are so fraught with peril for them.